[Music]
hi i'm carolyn grambling earth and
climate writer for science news in honor
of the 100th anniversary of our
independent news organization we are
interviewing leaders in science on the
big questions in their fields here we're
going to be talking about climate change
communication
that can include not only ongoing
research on how best to inoculate people
against climate science misinformation
but also how to just engage with people
on this topic in these highly polarized
times
my guest today is ed maybach who is the
director of the center for climate
change communication at george mason
university dr maybach researches public
understanding of and engagement in
climate change and looks for ways to
enhance both that understanding and that
engagement
along with his colleague anthony
lycerowitz at yale dr maybach received
the steven schneider award for
outstanding climate science
communication in 2020
and this is work that is needed now more
than ever so dr maybach thank you so
much for joining us
so in my introduction i mentioned to
these highly polarized times but of
course that's an oversimplification
people aren't just one thing or the
other and as you and your colleagues
reported about a decade ago there aren't
just two perspectives on global warming
in the united states uh you identified
six distinct perspectives on the in the
u.s on that subject
yeah absolutely um and you have it
exactly right carolyn it's like when i
when i started working on climate change
almost 15 years ago now
you know that sort of the lore out there
was that there are sort of just two
beliefs and i'm using that word beliefs
very intentionally here it drives some
of my climate science colleagues nuts
when they hear me talk about beliefs
because they their their business is is
evidence and facts not beliefs but
nevertheless the rest of us we we
hold beliefs about what we think
um our climates you know climate
scientists have concluded and the lore
was 15 years ago there were either there
were two types of americans those who
believed that global warming was real
and human caused and serious and those
who chose not to believe that and that
just struck tony and i as pretty
patently absurd of course there has to
be more more nuance than that um so we
did something that in in the marketing
field they call audience segmentation
analysis
it's pretty simple it's just using
statistical data people's answers to our
surveys and then running it through a
statistical algorithm to look at
look for people whose answers cluster
together whose answers are similar to
one another and what we found
essentially was that there are six six
distinct groups we call them global
warming six americas
and um it's been absolutely fascinating
to watch those six groups evolve over
the past
we first identified them in the
spring of 2009 so we we've been able to
watch them evolve over the past 12 years
and
and over the past five or six years it's
what's been particularly most notable
is that the
americans who were least inclined to
believe that human-caused climate change
is real we call them
in fact they're not inclined at all to
believe
they're quite firm in their convictions
that that global warming is not is is a
scam essentially um and that segment of
the public about five or six years ago
was one out of approximately one out of
ten twelve percent exactly um and over
the ensuing five or six years they have
contracted they're now down to about
seven percent that's something we didn't
expect to see because when when people
hold their views
uh strongly they tend to hold them
dearly as well they're not really mostly
they're not willing to to relinquish
their views change their views but at
the same time during that same time
period the group on the other end of the
six americas continuum which we call the
alarmed again about one out of ten five
or six years ago 12 exactly they have
grown enormously um well in excess of 25
now probably we're about to release our
latest data probably three and ten
thirty percent so there's been this
enormous growth in the proportion of
americans who are concerned really
deeply concerned about climate change
so i'm just going to give people a
little like um some of those the six
categories that you identified you
mentioned a few of them so it goes from
alarmed to concerned
to cautious
disengaged which i guess are the people
who just really don't have an opinion
one way or the other feel uninformed
about it i don't know if that's accurate
and then there's then there's doubtful
and then dismissive
um and
when you're doing these surveys like
twice a year since 2008 when you did the
first one is that right so that's why
you're doing this you're able to do this
sort of longitudinal like let's track
how these attitudes have changed and i
was interested to read that you there's
been it wasn't just sort of like this
uptick it was like there was a dip and
then it went back up again over time
there was a dip around 2010 2011. so if
you sort of talk about like what are the
things that are driving those trends in
in people's perceptions in your in your
viewpoint yeah it's a a very good
observation it hasn't been a
single linear trend either upward or
downward there's been a lot of um
a lot of wiggle wiggling in those trend
lines
and the very first uh
notable thing that we observed was
between our first and our second survey
so between the fall of 2008 and early
winter 2010
we didn't have
we didn't have the funding yet in place
to do
surveys every six months so it was a it
was essentially a year
year 14 months between the first two
surveys but our timing was absolutely
fortuitous in the sense that we caught
the high water mark of public concern
about climate change in the fall of
2008. if you look at gallup polls and
pew polls polls you know polls pro that
came prior to ours they were showing
along a sort of a long steady growth and
we we jumped into this polling process
right around the time of the high water
mark and then like an inconvenient truth
was the year before right so it was like
right right around that peak of interest
and knowledge
yeah an inconvenient truth was i guess
2006 perhaps so several years several
years prior what was actually going on
were two things two i mean a lot of a
lot of things were going on but two
things in particular that that i think
drove this dramatic
downturn in public concern about climate
change between the fall of 2008 and the
winter of 2010 the first one was the
financial markets melting down in
america and around the world
so you know if you recall lots of people
were were their mortgages were
underwater they were losing their jobs
it was really a terrible time
um
and but something else important
happened at that time and it was called
the waxman marquis bill and namely that
a comprehensive climate legislation
passed in the u.s house of
representatives
and
it was then being going to you know it
was going to become the job of the us
senate to essentially also ratify a bill
and and come up with a
um a reconciliation and and move
comprehensive climate legislation
forward to the president's desk
um and the president of course that was
president obama he would have signed it
um what happened in response to the
waxman marquee bill is the climate
denial machine kicked into high gear
like ludicrous speed if i can use a uh
a mel brooks reference here
um
you know
got it spaceballs exactly right um so
you know that the climate disinformation
machine is incredibly well funded um
incredibly disciplined and and when they
kick into ludicrous speed it's going to
have an impact and in fact that's
exactly the impact we saw between 2008
and 2010.
and so that sort of dovetailed with the
rise of the tea party as well as as a
political
power powerhouse i guess exactly right
yeah
but now we're seeing this like swing
back up and in fact past the point of
2008 as far as the alarmed and the
concerned friends that's right
that's right so so really for the past
10 years it hasn't been a perfect
incremental increase but for the past 10
years there has been this pretty
dramatic growth in public engagement on
all of the indicators that that we are
you know that our research shows are
most important
people which we boil down to by the way
five key indicators okay because there
there are really only five what we call
essential truths
that when people understand them when
americans understand them it
differentiates those people who are
quite concerned about the problem and
are starting to
take action themselves from those people
who aren't either are concerned or
aren't taking action and those five
essential truths are it's real meaning
global warming is real it's us it's
human caused
experts agree there's
virtually no disagreement among the
climate science community about the
reality of human-caused climate change
it's bad
meaning it's yes it's bad for polar
plants penguins and polar bears but it's
bad for people too it's really important
for people to understand it's not just a
threat to
you know charismatic species up up in
the far north but in fact it's it's
changing conditions in our backyard and
then finally there's hope
right so for people who feel like the
horse has left the barn there's nothing
we can do about this in in the words of
some of my most beloved climate
scientist friends who who like to
shorthand it as we're effed they say no
it's true we you know we are in for a
world of pain but the degree to which we
are aft depends on whether or not we
respond to this and so people who feel
like there is no hope are not likely to
be rolling up their sleeves and getting
engaged and
championing or personally engaging in
climate solutions i have to say when you
said there's hope those two words i
immediately like took a deep breath and
went okay
so yeah as a as a climate change
reporter over the last you know decade
and a half now i guess um yeah i i've
seen sort of this change
um in terms of you know
where people seem to be standing in
terms of you know denial outright denial
um
and for me i can sort of recognize what
i think of as inflection points there
where it's like okay the
2018 special report from the ipcc on the
one and a half degree
study that seemed like a thing that
really got people's attention you know
suggesting that one and a half degrees
versus two degrees you know there's
quantifiable differences and here's what
they are um and then you know the youth
climate movement in 2019 but your data
seemed to suggest that this change was
actually starting a little bit earlier
than that that people were becoming more
engaged and more aware
even before 2018
so i was curious what are the things
that might be driving
that particular
tick upward
i i i suspect most americans have paid a
lot more attention to
the youth climate movement and and to
young greta tunberg from from sweden
than they have paid to the ipcc's 1.5
degrees special report um i personally
pay a lot of attention to the to the
ipcc uh 1.5 degree report because it's
it's such an important statement that
they made
because the statement i'm sorry i'm sort
of going i'm answering a slightly
different question then you ask me but
i'm going with it anyway
the reason why the 1.5 degree report was
so important is because the the
all countries in the world minus hours
during the trump administration but now
once again we're back in the paris
climate agreement and all countries in
the world have agreed to work together
to try to limit global warming to no
more than two degrees centigrade
and yet they
were smart enough insightful enough to
ask the ipcc
is that actually safe you know that two
degrees turned out to be a politically
expedient number a number that all the
nations could agree on but it really
wasn't clear as to whether or not that
was a safe level of warming and so they
asked the scientists of the world in the
form of the ipcc to to do a special
report on exactly that would we be what
is the difference
for our children and our grandchildren
and their children and grandchildren etc
if we
limit the warming to 1.5 degrees or if
we let it go all the way up to two
degrees god forbid we don't go beyond
that
and what they found was that it's really
the difference is quite profound the the
public health i'm a public health
professional by training so i i tend to
think of all of this in public health
terms the public health consequences of
letting the warming get to two degrees
as opposed to 1.5 degrees is pretty
consequential not like i shouldn't say
pretty is extremely consequential there
will be a lot more public health harm if
the world warms to two degrees than if
we succeed in limiting the warming to
1.5 degree
and i do think so now coming back to
answer your question i do think the
public has paid attention to young
voices which is good they're our
children they're our grandchildren we
should pay attention to them they're
speaking truth to power and and in fact
they're speaking science to power i
think young greta is absolutely amazing
in the way she speaks science to power
but i also think that
america's health professionals have by
and large started to wake up and talk
about this issue which i think helps as
well i can tell you for a fact that
america's television weather casters
have really gotten in the game over the
past five six seven years um and so
there are lots of new voices who the
members of the public weren't previously
hearing who are now talking about
climate change and i think what we're
seeing in terms of this this
dramatically heightened public
engagement i think we're seeing that the
sum total of all of these new voices who
really you you could say they have ended
the climate silence that was reigning in
america up until about five or six years
ago most people simply didn't talk about
the issue and we learned we know that
from our surveys and we know from our
surveys that most people don't hear
anybody else talking about this uh
climate change is an issue whether
that's professionals or whether it's
their friends and family
so the fact that america has started a
conversation about climate change is
incredibly helpful because we're not
likely to to stand up and do anything
about our problems if we're not talking
yeah there was a scientist i talked to
back in 2019 it was kim cobb actually
georgia tech and she she was mentioning
like at that point after the youth
climate movement it just felt like
suddenly this was a kitchen table
discussion you know
it was something that people were
sitting down and actually talking about
amongst themselves
or in the grocery store or wherever as
opposed to you know just sort of some
rarefied
distant thing and it feels like you know
the extreme weather events also which
were again emphasized by this year's
ipcc report um to sort of bring it home
to people that seem to also um
help help make it more real i think yeah
yeah absolutely and you know so climate
scientists have been telling us for a
very long time that one of the ways that
climate change is going to touch our
lives first and most directly is through
extreme weather and
uh
10 years ago when we were when we asked
people the question have you personally
experienced global warming about one out
of four people would say yes to that
question
now about half of our polling response
respondents say yes to that question and
when we ask them well in what way have
you personally experienced global
warming we we see very clearly that that
more and more people are connecting the
dots between the extreme weather events
in their community and this thing that
they've been hearing about called
climate change
yeah i was also really struck by the the
most recent report that updates um the
six americas show that the
the smallest fraction is now the
disengaged fraction that it just goes to
show that more and more people are at
least coming down on one side or the
other and you know mostly on the on the
concerned or alarmed side yeah so i
thought that was really telling too
there's not very
there's there's fairly little
demographic difference between the the
six americas
the disengaged segment is the one sort
of exception to that rule
they um
they have less household income they
they're just they're essentially a group
of americans who are working twice as
hard just to keep you know keep paying
the rent or keep paying the mortgage and
so the reason they are disengaged is not
because they don't care it's because
they don't have time to actually pay
attention to
to
sort of the news that that had they if
they did have more time they might
otherwise be paying attention to so yes
the disengaged segment has shrunk
considerably over the past decade and
although i don't actually know the
numbers off the top of my head i can
tell you rather than sort of inching
along to the next group over the
cautious and then the concerned and then
the alarmed my guess is many of them
jumped straight from the disengage
segment into the alarm segment
yeah i was gonna i wanted to ask you
about um you know so now that you have
done this work to sort of know the
audience
what how how is it helpful to develop
climate communication strategies to to
be able to identify these different
groups how can you tailor different
strategies to the different groups
it's a great question and to some degree
we do exactly that but
the way the biggest insight for me
personally with the in the six americas
continuum
um is the was the following realization
the alarm segment again they've grown
enormously so when i first started
thinking about the alarm segment they
weren't nearly as big and important as
they are today but but even then
that the goal there the the climate
communication objective there shouldn't
be to further worry them because they're
worried enough
it should actually be to help them
understand the actions that they could
take that will be really genuinely
helpful
um and we know from our polling that
lots of people have a very even in the
alarm segment have a very unclear idea
about what actions are going to be
genuinely most helpful
so with regard to the alarm we we try to
and we try to help organizations who are
targeting the alarm segment
understand look help these people figure
out what's most what's most important
for them to do because they want to take
action
on the other end of the continuum the
dismissive segment
frankly we you know we don't go after
them we're we're not in the business of
trying to convince people who who don't
want to be convinced of the truth it's
just really hard to do that um and you
know if others
if there are organizations who are
trying to
um
trying to debunk the the misinformation
that characterizes their thinking god
bless them um
that's not the way i choose to spend my
time i choose to spend my time on the
four americas in the middle of the
continuum and the reason is because to a
greater or lesser degree they already
understand that the climate is changing
the the one the group that we call the
doubtful which is right next to the
dismissive they they tend to be
skeptical but they're still listening
they tell us very clearly in our surveys
they are still open to learning more and
as long as so just because they're a
little skeptical now as long as they're
still open to learning more i see that
as a real opportunity
so the four segments in the middle of
the continuum
we have spent a fair amount of our
effort trying to build communication
programs that reach out to them that
help them either understand you know as
i said before that that it's real that
it's us that experts agree that it's bad
and their their actions we can take that
will make a difference
um for the segments who are
already inclined to understand that it's
happening what our objective there is to
help them realize this isn't only a
future problem
this is today's problem this problem is
already changing conditions in your
backyard and in ways that you know
sometimes are nice it's
gorgeous where i live today i went
outside for a uh for a little while
today and i was just stunned at how
lovely it is you know i understand why
it's so lovely and and the reason isn't
good
but it it but it was it is lovely today
um so we try to help people understand
people who see climate change is a
distant problem distant in space
somewhere else not here in my community
distant in time
2050 2100 yeah but not 2021 and distant
species polar bears but not people we
try to help all of them realize no in
fact this is happening now here in our
community to us and it's not good for us
and and we have you know real strong
reason to believe from our research that
when people learn
those facts they learn the ways that
it's changing conditions are changing in
their backyard now and why that isn't
good it really it helps to heighten this
this public engagement that we've been
talking about
i was going to ask i mean i'll give you
an opportunity to critique journalists
you know so this is obviously you know i
think in general in climate journalism
there's certainly been an increase in
you know recognition that we need to
tell personal stories local stories make
it bring it home to people in that way
and i'm curious you know what what do
you think that climate journalists like
me could be doing to to tell this story
in a way that might actually be
impactful for the for that middle
yeah um
like the old expression that all
politics is local i tend to think that
you know all climate change engaged
public engagement comes from local
motivations so i i really do believe
that we've got you know science news
does wonderful
climate journalism um the new york times
the washington post
are absolutely outstanding the la times
we have some premier news uh
journalistic outlets that are doing
outstanding climate reporting
but
i would like to see
everyday news stations both tv radio
newspapers digital news outlets i'd like
to see them covering climate change as a
local issue because people can only be
expected to care so much or to pay so
much attention when they learn about
what's happening elsewhere because
they're primarily interested in what's
happening here in in our town um so i
think we have a real profound need to
help journalists around the country and
around the world um
do highly engaging local climate
reporting contextualizing the global
story in the form of local stories
what's happening here to us now
so in the vein of uh you know figuring
out a way to to bring the story and make
it personal and relevant to individuals
i know that you have this story that you
have told before um about a neighbor
uh who you
i'm gonna make you tell that story do
you mind do you mind sharing that one
again i think it's really interesting
i don't mind i really ought to tell my
neighbor that i'm sharing
our stories
that you talk about but i i actually
don't think she would bind um so i i've
lived in this neighborhood for a good
long time more than two decades now and
for the first decade or so
um a neighbor two doors down her name is
nancy she um she felt the need to remind
me every time we talked
that she is a um
i'm forgetting what kind of republican
she tells me she is but basically she
reminds me i think you've said i could
just tell you i think it's i think it
was a gold watercolor a gold plastic
that's exactly right
i i wanted to say a rockefeller
republican and i knew that wasn't right
a goldwater republican which is which is
even more conservative than a
rockefeller republican by a long yard
and i really wasn't sure what about me
that that was eliciting this need in her
to remind me that she is a goldwater
republican but whatever we she she and i
were perfectly cordial there was never
any
animosity or strife between us um but
she and my wife and some of the other
people in our um on our block are in a
reading club a book club and one night
she i came home from work late i was
teaching a night course and um nancy was
in my home with a bunch of other of our
neighbors and nancy wandered away from
the book club conversation and she
wandered into the kitchen when i was
eating the leftovers from the book club
like i won there
and we and we had a long chat and it the
long chat came from the fact that i real
i remembered that she had told me that
she's a vegan of three decades
and i you know it it really hadn't
occurred to me until that night to ask
her what's a good nice rockefeller
goldwater republican like you you know
do with eating a vegan diet and so i
asked her i didn't ask her that way but
i asked her sincerely and it it launched
us into the most amazing
intimate conversation about her real
deep feelings about the well-being of
animals and she just can't bring herself
to eat animals because she feels too
much empathy for them and to to want to
end their lives or her for the benefit
of you know her
her nutritional needs or or or desires
or desires right and and that you know
letting her talk to me about her
motivations and what she cared about
can
it brought her around to asking me about
my motivations and what i care about and
why is it that i work on global warming
and and it gave me an opportunity to
tell her exactly why i don't really
remember the details of this part of the
conversation but i'm pretty sure i care
i i couched it in who i am as a person
and as a professional i'm i'm first
foremost and always a public health
professional this is how i've spent the
past four decades of my life working on
behalf of
ensuring that we can all live a healthy
and fulfilled lives
and explaining climate change to her as
being rooted you know why i'm working on
it is because i am a health professional
and i can't possibly stand by and watch
us
destroy
the climate which is the most
fundamental determinant of human health
and and
being able to make my case to her and
explain it from the perspective of my
values brought her up made her
comfortable enough to ask me a lot of
follow-up questions questions that she
had in her mind about global warming but
had never
found the created the opportunity to ask
anyone but because we were having a real
moment there she felt comfortable asking
me about the ants did i know the answer
to these questions and i would say we
spoke for the better part of 45 minutes
about this and it was it was really a
moment i i treasure it yeah i was
thinking you know it's we're going into
the thanksgiving season when people are
going to have these interactions with
people and one does wonder you know
is what what are some tips that that you
might recommend for having those
for creating those moments i guess i
mean you i guess you're looking for the
common ground
yeah um i hear that question a lot and
and and behind the question i there's
usually
um an assumption and the assumption is
how can i win the argument
and i think that's a really really bad
way to think about the whole thing um
and it's totally understandable why you
would you know if you want to engage
right right you're alarmed and and lots
of alarm people would like to talk to
their loved ones their neighbors their
their friends their family um but
they're worried that it will start a
fight and they're worried that they that
they somehow have to
you know essentially be
become mini-me climate scientists and or
be able to channel climate scientists to
to you know put all the facts on the
table and win the debate but that's just
not the way it works the way it works is
you show people how much you care and
and once you've shown them how much you
care and why you care then they might
actually be interested in in posing some
questions and examining some you know
aspects of this that they otherwise
really wouldn't be in the least bit
interested in talking about it so
you know what i recommend is that if you
want to talk to people about climate
change and i hope everybody wants to
talk to people about climate change just
start with you know
telling people how much you care and why
you care and that's likely to lead to a
really good conversation
um so
it's funny as you were mentioning the
thing about wanting to win an argument
which
fair
um you know i'm also thinking about like
the
the sort of research that's been going
on and i've written a little bit about
um on climate misinformation
disinformation and efforts to combat
that um and i'm curious you know what is
your
you know this is it's an interesting
arena because it brings in these areas
of you know of cognitive science and
social psychology into the climate space
um
and i'm
you know there are all these like
tactics that people are trying to
counter with other kinds of tactics i'm
curious about what your what your
thoughts are on on on how those efforts
are are moving forward
and you mentioned earlier i know that
you're like well god bless those people
for
no no no this this is a really important
question and i'm going to couch my i'm
going to catch the start of my answer in
what i know as a public health
communication scientist okay so before i
started working on climate change i i i
hold a degree in public health and
another degree in communication science
and i did that very purposefully because
i i wanted my career to focus on how do
we use communication
to help people not just
not just
ordinary people but our policy makers in
particular how do we use information to
help people make better decisions
decisions that will more reliably allow
us to to more people to live long and
helpfully
and there's one and only one thing i
know for sure in my four decades of
study on that on that question and that
is
every successful public health campaign
in human history probably every
successful communication campaign of any
type in human history has i has
succeeded on the basis of having simple
clear messages
repeated often by a variety of trusted
voices
and you know the trusted voices part is
important because
we
we don't necessarily all trust the same
people right so
i would contend that donald trump is an
absolute master of simple clear messages
repeating them often through his own
trusted voice and getting people in his
in his
uh milieu uh to repeat his simple clear
messages and that was a very very
powerful driving force in america over
the past four years and still is
very much so um it you know much of what
he's saying has no no basis in truth
certainly no basis in scientific truth
um but if we want but for those people
who are trying to communicate scientific
truths that will help people make better
decisions we have to use that same
toolkit simple clear messages repeated
often by a variety of trusted voices
it helps to get the repeated often part
it really helps to have a lot of money
so if i am you know royal dutch shell or
or bp or exxon mobile or chevron i have
a lot of money to spend to get my simple
clear messages out to the american
people and people around the world and
right now what do i want them to know i
want them to know that we we've got this
we accept the fact that the climate is
changing but we are putting our best
people and and on the task of creating
new sources of clean renewable energy so
you folks don't need to worry about it
and it's a wonderful thing for them to
tell us to tell me i hear it every day
on my npr radio station i hear i see it
in my twitter feed i it's i i feel like
i'm surrounded 360 degrees by the fossil
fuel industry telling me that they've
got this thing it's okay
um but the way they do it is because
they've got a lot of money to get
message repetition they can they
literally pay to get their messages in
front of me
the climate science community they don't
have that kind of budget so they and and
frankly they're they
and we are not so good at the simple the
simple clear message i was thinking that
yeah
yeah yeah so we have some work to do on
simple clear messages yeah taking the
complexity of climate change and climate
solutions and rendering it simple
we've got a lot of work to do on getting
the message repetition way up there
and if we can do those two things though
simplify our messaging
make sure that we're finding ways to get
those messages out frequently
the people
who are most concerned about climate
change like you and me
we will actually incorporate those that
way of thinking and those messages into
our own vocabulary into our own
dialogues with our friends and family
and that's really the power of simple
clear messages because the most trusted
people in all of our lives are the
people who are closest to us
so it really helps when your messages
are simple and clear because members of
your target audience will eventually
become the conveyors of those messages
so coming back to answer your question
the the climate denial industry has been
changing how has been shaping public
understanding of climate change for many
many decades now they've been talking
about it for much longer than the
climate science community
so we have a very hard job of undoing
the damage that they have done in terms
of shaping our pub our understanding of
climate change in ways that are
fundamentally just not true and
fundamentally um
intended to make us not care about
climate change to make us think that
it's a distant threat not a not a
problem
or that there's nothing we can do or
that we should pay most attention to our
own carbon footprint which is completely
ludicrous because while it is good to
reduce our own carbon footprint we're
never going to solve this problem we're
never going to keep the warming to 1.5
degrees or even 2 degrees if what we're
worried about is our individual carbon
foot footprints
what we need to worry about is making
sure that there that every nation in the
world has a real climate action plan and
that that plan is focused laser-like on
limiting global warming to no more than
1.5 degrees celsius which is why the
upcoming climate meeting in glasgow
scotland cop26 is so incredibly
important
i was about to ask you you're about to
jet off to to glasgow is that right to
attend this meeting okay
and i was gonna say what are you what do
you you know
what are you looking for when you when
you go to this meeting what is your this
sort of is going to segue into a future
question what gives you hope but i guess
you know for now focused on this meeting
you know what what what needs to happen
there in your view yeah okay so it was a
great thing
what gives i'm actually going to start
to introduce what gives me hope the
paris climate agreement gave me hope
because the paris climate agreement was
the first time that every nation in the
world came together and agreed on a goal
the goal they agreed to limiting climate
change the limiting global warming to no
more than two degrees
turns out to be not such a prudent goal
but at least it's a goal right we got
that we got that going for us which is
nice um
but uh you know now we need to reset
that goal down to 1.5 degrees c
and there are a lot of voices out there
including a lot of nations that really
aren't interested in in lowering the
goal making a more ambitious goal of
limiting to 1.5 degrees c so it's
incredibly important that as many
science-based voices
um
will be present at that meeting
fighting in ever
fighting for
that you know upping our game going
going big so that we can really try to
limit the warming to something that
could be
reasonably considered safe for humanity
so what i'm hoping for is that we that
countries will increase what are called
their ndc's they're nationally
determined contributions
no country has to do anything it's
totally voluntary but if the people
if
in in my case i am going as a health
professional so if health professionals
show up at the meeting and make it
perfectly clear to our nation's leaders
who are representing us at that meeting
that we expect them to become more
aspirational we expect them to fight
hard not only to make bigger more
ambitious ndcs but to push other nations
to do the same
so that's what i'm hoping will happen at
cop26 and you know that gives me hope
that there's still a chance that we can
we can have an impact
every tenth of a degree of warming that
we avert
will will pay profound dividends
profound benefits for humanity so i
don't want to pretend as if there's
something magical about 1.5 or 2 degrees
c but every tenth of a degree of warming
that we can prevent is going to be
really a blessing to humanity going
forward
yeah so i guess you know this the flip
side you know this is it's been a really
tough
uh a couple of years really exhausting
and grueling both due to covet and and
for you know extreme weather events and
you know
having hopes sometimes feeling dashed
about climate progress
um so i guess
you know
i wanted to ask first you know
do how what what what are your climate
anxieties what what what do you feel
discouraged about and then you know the
flip side of that is like how do you how
do you counter that for yourself i guess
how do you
how do you you know reach for that hope
even even in the middle of this
of this uh
i don't know what the word is mess
yeah yeah i know right right now i feel
most discouraged that
one possibly two u.s senators are are in
a position to essentially
put the kibosh on what otherwise would
have been a really thoughtful
appropriate ambitious
comprehensive climate package called the
build back better act um it's just
really perplexing to me that that um i
recognize that uh this is obviously a
hyperpolarized issue and um that elected
officials want to keep their jobs so
they want to make sure that they are not
uh
stepping out in front of and running
afoul of their constituents
but this is a you know this is an all
hands on deck moment here and and we
have we have a moment in america where
we could really do what is necessary to
not
not do everything that is necessary but
take a major first step towards
comprehensive climate action that will
make us
for the first time a real leader in the
world and the world needs real leaders
right now i don't have a you know i
don't think americans should have sort
of that that sense that the world can't
do it without us but we are so
big our economy is so big we have been
such
major
carbon polluters for so long we have an
obligation to be leaders it's not just
that we can but we have an obligation to
do it so i'm a little bit dispirited
right now that it looks like the
comprehensive climate legislation won't
go through
um but i also try to take the long view
and realize okay we'll just just means
we have to work harder and hope to
create enough public will
to create enough political will so that
next year or the year after or the year
after we will see the us congress do
what is really necessary
well i i certainly am reaching for that
hope as well
i agree i feel a little bit dispirited
but i'm trying to sort of you know take
the long view i think that maybe that's
the
that's the only way to sort of
move forward and and the the idea of
also you know trying to
to connect with people um and and do
what we can to
to build that story and and and get the
get the information out to people even
in the middle of
you know even
and maybe not the dismissive folks but
the rest of the folks um yeah
to answer your question about how do i
contain my own anxieties so i can
continue to be productive i have a dear
friend she's an emergency room physician
in yellowknife northern territories
canada and her name is courtney howard
and courtney says
i don't worry anymore i just do the work
and i i love that i love when she says
that i wish i were like her i do still
worry but the way i try to contain my
worry so that i can continue to do the
work is i've created a mental lock box
and whenever i whenever i get new
information to help that that i feel is
important to update my own understanding
of where we are with regard to our
changing climate and what our what our
most
attractive uh solution options are i
open up the box i i pay attention to the
information and then if it's at least if
it's
dire information i shove it back in the
box and then i slam the box shut and i
leave it shut and i only open it when i
need to update the information that's in
there and the rest of the time i just
focus on giving my best shot at trying
to help people mostly americans but to
some degree my work is focused in around
the world especially with within my work
with health professionals
you know i try to focus on doing my best
work today and i find that that's
enormously
um i don't know cathartic i i guess in a
sense uh staying staying in the present
allows me to to give my best shot every
day i was finding that thought grounding
yes exactly
yeah well dr maybach thank you so much
for such an informative and um
eye-opening conversation and uh viewers
you can learn more about dr maybach's
work and keep up with the latest
research on climate change by visiting
us at
sciencenews.org and connecting with us
on social media so thanks for joining us
and thank you again thank you carolyn
[Music]
you